imaginez la scène vous demandez leur à
un ami et il vous répond il fait 20
degrés vous allez vous dire qu'il a mal
entendu votre question donc vous allez
la répéter mais imaginez qu'il insiste
qu'il vous réponde encore il fait 20
degrés cette fois-ci vous allez vous
dire qu'il a un problème et vous allez
peut-être vous énervez pourquoi parce
que votre amie est hors sujet qu'est ce
que le hors sujet et bien c'est quand
vous répondez à côté on vous demande de
réfléchir un problème ah mais vous vous
réfléchissez à un problème b par exemple
si je vous demande si la démocratie est
le meilleur régime politique et que vous
me répondez que l'argent on ne rend pas
heureux
là vous êtes hors sujet très
grossièrement hors sujet dans la
pratique ce n'est pas binaire comme ça
vous n'êtes pas soit dans le sujet soit
hors du sujet les éléments de réponse
que vous apportez dans votre
dissertation sont plus ou moins
pertinents donc vous pouvez être 20%
hors sujet ou 70 % hors sujet par
exemple imaginer une jauge de pertinence
vous devez être le plus à droite
possible ça sera plus facile avec les
trois astuces que je vais vous donner
dans cette vidéo mais vous avez d'abord
besoin d'une méthodologie solide
ça tombe bien et j'ai ce qu'il vous faut
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie de la dissertation soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant haut à droite de la vidéo
souhaitent en cliquant sur celui qui est
dans la description de cette vidéo d'un
cours par email simple et pratique pour
gagner rapidement des points en
dissertation et en particulier mon cours
réduit le risque que vous commettiez un
hors sujet mais les trois astuces que je
vais vous révéler ne sont pas dans ce
court regardez donc attentivement cette
vidéo jusqu'au bout et contrairement à
tous les autres candidats vous vous
serez immunisé contre le hors sujet
quelle est la meilleure garantie lorsque
vous traversez la route de ne pas vous
faire renverser alors oui mieux vaut
traverser au vert mais bon en france la
discipline c'est pas dans notre adn
non la meilleure garantie de ne pas se
faire renverser
c'est simplement d'examiner soi même la
circulation pour savoir si la voix est
libre
bon et bien fait la même chose en
dissertation lorsque vous analysez le
sujet après l'avoir découvert
réfléchissez aux risques du hors sujet
demandez vous s'il ya un piège si le
libellé du sujet semble vous induire en
erreur
ça peut vous paraître bête comme astuce
mais c'est en réalité un filtre très
puissants en général les élèves qui
commettent un sujet n'ont pas réfléchi à
ce risque lorsqu'ils ont commencé à
analyser le sujet souvenez vous donc que
lorsque vous analysez le sujet au début
d'épreuve vous devez simplement vous
poser la question est ce que je risque
de faire ma hors sujet c'est tout simple
mais c'est un réflexe qui peut faire une
énorme différence
je vous donne un exemple la seconde fois
que j'ai passé le concours de l'ena
c'était en 2014 le sujet de la
dissertation de culture générale était
la résistance est elle un idéal du 21e
siècle
je me suis demandé s'il y avait un
risque de hors sujet et j'en ai
identifié 1 est ce que vous le voyez
c'est le mot résistance qui crée le
risque d'un côté résistance avec un
grand r ça désignait la résistance
intérieure française
c'est à dire la lutte clandestine sur le
territoire français contre les nazis et
la collaboration de 1940 à 1944
mais de l'autre côté la résistance
renvoie aussi plus généralement tout
simplement à l'acte de résister à un
pouvoir
en clair quand j'ai lu le sujet je me
suis dit résistance française ou
résistance en général
est ce que je serai hors sujet si je
parle uniquement de la responsable si je
n'en parle pas j'ai réfléchi
stratégiquement et je suis arrivé à la
conclusion que j'avais intérêt a
mentionné la résistance française
mais que je devais élargir le problème
intellectuel à l'acte politique de
résister et j'ai touché juste le jury a
considéré que les copies qui parlait
uniquement de la résistance française
était hors sujet et aussi que celles qui
ne l'a
mentionnez pas était fautive c'est donc
parce que j'ai eu le bon réflexe dès le
début de l'épreuve que j'ai pu trouver
le bon dosage
mais parfois la première astuce ne
suffit pas la plupart du temps lorsqu'on
vous pose une question vous ne répondez
pas à côté
n'est ce pas alors pourquoi est ce que
c'est si difficile en dissertation parce
que ce sont des questions abstraites et
général or la communication humaine
n'est pas faite pour répondre à ce genre
de questions elle est faite pour
résoudre des problèmes concrets et
précis par exemple est ce que tu as vu
un lyon près de notre territoire
ou bien est ce que tu veux bien partager
ton repas avec moi mais si la question
c'est qu'est ce que le bonheur
là on a les fils qui se touchent et on
risque d'être hors sujet c'est pour ça
que je vous conseille de chercher des
exemples concrets et précis
c'est ça ma deuxième astuces concret ça
veut dire que la chose peut être perçue
par les sens et précis ça veut dire que
la chose ne peut pas être divisés en
éléments plus petits plutôt que d'errer
dans le ciel des idées pour parler comme
platon revenait sur la terre ferme
et là il sera plus facile de délimiter
le champ intellectuel que couvre le
sujet je vous donne un exemple il y a
quelques années et j'ai cherché des
exemples pour traiter le sujet le livre
de la nature
j'ai pensé à une encyclopédie sur la
nature comme l'histoire naturelle de
bouffonne un célèbre naturaliste du
xviiie siècle
j'ai aussi pensé à un récit sur
l'origine du monde comme celui qui lie à
dans la bible par exemple j'ai enfin
penser que si on regroupait toutes les
lois sur lesquels repose le
fonctionnement de la nature et la
gravité par exemple eh bien on pourrait
dire que toutes ces lois qui ensemble
forment un conte plus on pourrait dire
qu'elles sont un livre les trois
exemples que je viens de vous présenter
mon permis de comprendre que dans
l'expression
le livre de la nature le livre peut
fournir une explication du
fonctionnement de la nature ou bien
faire le récit de la nature les exemples
m'ont également permis de comprendre que
le livre peut désigner un vrai livre un
ouvrage avec des pages qui se tournent
mais le terme peut aussi prendre un sens
symbolique est désigné seulement un
contenu de l'information pure qui
seraient susceptibles d'être rassemblés
dans un vrai livre un contenu comme les
lois de la nature
en cherchant des exemples je me suis
donc rendu compte que le chant du sujet
était assez large
c'est à dire que je pouvais parler de
pas mal de choses tout en restant dans
le sujet et si les deux premières
d'astuces ne suffisent pas il en reste
encore une dernière pour vérifier que
vous ne commettez pas un hors sujet il
ya une autre raison pour laquelle c'est
plus facile d'être dans le sujet quand
on vous pose une question dans la vie
quotidienne c'est la proximité de la
question et de la réponse comme on
répond en généralement quelques secondes
après la question la question est
toujours dans notre mémoire à court
terme et donc notre esprit peut
facilement évaluer la correspondance
entre la question et la réponse ma
troisième astuce consiste donc à créer
la même proximité entre la question et
la réponse en dissertation
c'est ce que j'appelle le test de
pertinence c'est très simple une fois
que vous avez trouvé les grandes parties
de votre plan vous lisez à la suite la
problématique qui est la question et
votre annonce de plan qui doit
constituer la réponse à votre
problématique et après vous faites
simplement au travail et votre sens
humain de la communication si vous
posiez la question de votre
problématique à quelqu'un et qu'il vous
réponde est votre annonce de plan est ce
que ça serait une réponse pertinente ou
bien est-ce que vous feront seriez les
sourcils en vous disant que ce n'est pas
ce que vous lui avez demandé
on revient à un bon point de départ la
question du hors sujet en dissertation
revient en dernière instance à celle de
l'efficacité de la communication humaine
nous les êtres humains sommes faits pour
vivre ensemble en communauté or
l'efficacité de notre coopération dépend
de l'efficacité de notre communication
si nous sommes hors sujet donc vous
changes quotidien la société ne peut pas
fonctionner je vous donne également un
exemple pour cette dernière astuce
faisons le test de pertinence pour ma
dissertation sur le sujet l'homme et
l'animal que j'ai publié sur cette
chaîne youtube
je vais lire à la suite ma problématique
et mon annonce de plan dans quelle
mesure l'homme dit fertile vraiment de
l'animal si l'homme semble se définir
lui même comme un être vivant
radicalement supérieur à l'animal il ne
peut cependant pas nié la part
d'animalité qui le caractérise mais
c'est en dépassant l'animal qui est en
lui que l'être humain accomplirait son
humanité
alors bien sûr la correspondance n'est
pas aussi flagrante que dans un échange
de la vie quotidienne mais on se rend
bien compte que l' annonce de plan
constitue une réponse pertinente à la
problématique c'est bon vous êtes
désormais immunisé contre leur sujet il
vous suffit de vous demander s'il ya un
risque lorsque vous analysez le sujet au
début de l'épreuve de chercher des
exemples concrets et précis et enfin de
faire un test de pertinence avec votre
problématique et votre annonce de plan
mais je voulais dit la meilleure
garantie c'est une méthodologie de la
dissertation solide
inscrivez vous donc à mon cours gratuits
de méthodologie de la dissertation soit
en cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant roux à droite de la vidéo
soit en cliquant sur celui qui est dans
la description de cette vidéo alors à
l'e3 astuces que je vous ai donné c'est
un détail à côté de mon cours de
méthodologie
mais un jour elle vous sauveront
peut-être la mise je suis romain je suis
toujours avec mon fidèle aristote et
vous étiez sur mille de culture générale
rappelez vous que vous n'avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour éviter le
hors sujet en dissertation
[Musique]